these children have spent the best part
of the night
begging for food and money they've been
abandoned here in cameroon's far north
region near the nigerian border
they will not keep what they get instead
they'll give it to this religious
teacher who
in exchange gives them shelter water and
occasionally
teaches them prayers sometimes he allows
a charity in
they offer mats for children to sleep on
and teach them to read and write
but the children are distracted most
have been
abused many have witnessed their fathers
being killed
or mothers being raped by boko haram
fighters who entered their villages
like eight-year-old mohammed
when i grow up i want to be a soldier
because
boko haram killed my father we were
picking millet
when i saw them slit my father's throat
and take my mother away ten-year-old
abdul usman hopes
his father will come back to get him
boko haram came to my village and they
picked up all the kids but i ran away
my father well my father i don't know
where he is
thousands of children have been
separated from their parents either
abducted by boko haram or orphaned
by the conflict between government
forces and the fighters
children who have escaped from the armed
group are seen with suspicion
with schools refusing to enroll them and
the state authorities unwilling to
register them
the u.n says state authorities are
failing the children they are meant to
protect
we have to recognize something children
develop skills
when they're with armed groups they
develop an incredible sense of
resilience sometimes leadership
it's it's not it's an illicit kind of
function but they nevertheless
do develop some skills and some of those
skills we need to capture and
and reinforce as well as help them get
over the very negative experiences
abukar is one such
child while he has lost his parents and
continues to beg on the streets
he has joined a state school he says he
wants to be a doctor
not only to heal his country but
the children of cameroon who've been
abandoned
but worthy of care nicholas hawk
al jazeera